what is up there reject nation we are
here for hawkeye episode four today coy
thanks for showing up with us here
tonight at midnight ladies and gentlemen
if you can go ahead and hit that like
button that would be very much
appreciated also please go ahead
subscribe and click the notification
bell to get notified when our reaction
for the next hawkeye episode is up koi
double double fisting every week
gotta stay balanced like this midnight
hot guy let's go pictures of that
equilibrium full-length watch along so
you sync up with the timecoder over at
our patreon page uh you can seek over
the time code there we cover many shows
at the same tier you get the optional
reaction highlights and watch along
included and yeah mainly follow coy over
at his youtube channel this guy really
knows comics he's hosted a bunch of
comic related panels and posts and all
kinds of gigs galore thanks to the boys
of our prepper for helping us edit down
these highlights do you boys think
kingpin might come in this episode i
think two out of three of us were
daredevil shirts for a reason i wear
this beanie every week
[Music]
what the hell is going on
and why is there an avenger in my dining
room
hi
oh my god
yo
you're archer hawkeye
mother so they don't know each other
okay i'm generally just pretty chill you
know i'm not like oh my god hawkeye
definitely not sure
by the way thank you
for saving the world
[Laughter]
so kate is helping you with an avengers
level threat well not exactly
but you are working together
yes
well i guess i'm just gonna have to
trust everyone at this table
to do what's right
i'd like my sore back
she is not a superhero
oh yeah come on into that i mean she's
pretty good at all this but natasha
romanov was pretty damn good at it
wasn't she
damn madame
it's been a rough week for my family but
i am letting you know that i cannot lose
kate i've lost people before i know in
your line of work you have to i
understand
okay i'd like to just get the [ __ ] out
of here i've been very comfortable for
lunch
[Laughter]
you got the sword
yeah
whoo
smooth
laura's like a guy does work in the 40s
he said that his boss jack dukane never
gives him a day off jack's ceo
are you laundering money for the big guy
let me guess you're gonna need another
day
physically large man
you know what they say
life is short you never know what you're
gonna get
[Laughter]
every time you use one of those
aphorisms they're wrong
you said
absence makes the heart grow older
because that's what it does
[Music]
getting laughed at my family it's better
than being alone in the holidays right
that's what it's all about
i'm so glad that you're both here
let's get some coronas yeah
that was such a sweet scene
very sweet it's about to get bad
yep
buddy
[Music]
alone
for the holiday
it's me come bearing pizza and holiday
let me in this is the classic hawkeye
costume we've been waiting for
what oh no
talk about sword boy for a minute you
got good instincts kid
what do you mean i did a little digging
oh [ __ ] yeah
as long as a shell company that launders
money for the tracksuits
and jack the kane
is the ceo we're just gonna have to come
up with a plan to take down my mom's
fiance's organized crime ring while
simultaneously having a heartwarming
holiday celebration
the thanos is right mug
you ever heard of boomerang arrows what
why would i ever want to use a boomerang
arrow
no
exactly
old trick arrows were boomerangs then
we'd have them all coming back at us
i call [ __ ] i've tried it well i've
done it a few times
he's wearing an ugly cat sweater and he
he looks like ugly cat i've ever seen
that meme yeah
he's wearing a face of his own face as a
cat
fine live forever without me believing
you i'll just tell every stranger that i
see hawkeyes
[Music]
merry christmas movie house
how'd she do witchcraft
burn her
another time i met someone oh
i was sent to take her out and when i
got there
when it was time
i couldn't do it
i just
had this feeling that you wanted out
turns out i was right you mean natasha
yeah
she was the best it was
i'm sorry
it's all right it's uh when you do what
i do for a living it um it's just a game
of managing loss right
such a realistic performance man it's
almost as if jeremy renner's a great
actor that's so weird
it took all this time to find out two
academy award nominees emotionally
connecting is that where you met the
ronin
don't tell her
she's buddy good to get
it's you isn't it
[Music]
killing all these people is gonna bring
your family back
oh [ __ ]
what my tracer arrows stopped moving
it's over by an nypd facility down by
the bridge and now the larpers they're
mostly first responders one's a cop
[Laughter]
is it our arrows
okay go get our error
let's scooby do this thing
i like that the uh her outfits evolving
like the kate bishop hawkeye outfit is
piecing together
hawkeye sent me here on official
avengers business i'm uh his partner's
lush best friend kate best friend
hawkeye's trick arrows are in an nypd
facility near the manhattan bridge
i can probably help you out
if you make it worth my while let me
kill you
what's up girls
surprise
i love that trip
look i know you have maya's ear
and you seem like you're reasonably not
stupid guy if you're trying to flatter
me you're way off the mark oh don't get
me wrong i think you're a doormat
you know what my boss wants you know
he's already done to get it so what do
you know i know he doesn't like his
attention that's for sure
hey can i have my gun back
yeah okay
come on
i can't go get the gun now yeah
it's probably half a block away
being stacked on top of two or three
cars
snickerdoodle it's still warm okay
egg girls is back bakes
what if that's our deal what deal we get
you the arrows and info
and you get us materials for a new
costume enough materials to make your
costumes plus two more that's how they
get the suit someone who needs a little
help with theirs
yes
oh goody oh hi arrow retrieval mission
complete
oh yes thank you so much i appreciate it
this is my bag
okay you didn't bring your own bag
uh no i mean my wife gave me this bag
it's embroidered it says
bombshell
[Laughter]
hawkeye smoke
god what have we done
what have we done
so this whole episode is about now
jesus
like i told you you're supposed to be
lookout yeah but of the two of us who do
you trust that they're not to get
distracted look it's not fair that your
ability to act like a grown-up helps you
get your way
box i'm taking the elevator
i'm sorry what was that
oh yeah
i'm sorry i wasn't talking to you
can i tell you a secret please don't do
this
i was talking to an avenger
i'm at the door
we're good
oh man kingpin's going to be in there
eating a pizza there he is
[Laughter]
[ __ ]
a lot of boomerangs right there mm-hmm i
thought they can introduce the
australian character known as boomerang
jackford
universe
maybe that blinking lights a little bit
of a signal yep oh
oh what is that there are like straw
blades to touch the wall it's robot what
do you mean strobe light i don't know
what am i looking for
a watch oh
i don't like the voyeuristic way they're
shooting this
got the watch
clint somebody is taking notes on your
family oh [ __ ] no
okay
get out of there now what
why that light's an alarm it's a silent
alarm for people that can't hear oh oh
[ __ ] his apartment
all right i'm coming
clint what's going on
maya's here i can see that
then why didn't you tell me
no i did
mine is on the roof with me
what
what
masked who the hell am i fighting then
oh yelena oh
it's gotta be right
get on the zipline
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
nice
[Music]
it's got to be god
[Music]
yes
[Laughter]
and it's gonna be weird for clint
[Music]
yeah
oh
oh
pull me up
get out of here
[Music]
she ain't gonna take that advice
wow
take it off yeah
we just want the confirmation
dark avengers starts now let us know no
no
[Music]
oh ouch
[Music]
yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's definitely
gotta be
[Applause]
someone is hired
the black widow assassin so i'm doing
this alone i chose to be here i
understand the risk i understand all of
that
go home kate
it's over
[Music]
i got the emotion and the action you
know your name sounded like bernie but
they know
they know that's the point they're okay
with it it's so funny because when she
was fighting maya i thought did go off
my head for a second of like there's
only two episodes left how are they
gonna get you later yeah she's not gonna
come in
how are they going to get you later
because the last episode's going to be
like a movie it's going to be like a big
chunk cliffhanger like episode 5 is
going to end crazy
three women fighting kingpin
punching him in the belly
[Laughter]
quality television
or he doesn't think like spider-man
squeeze but
taurus shoe is absolutely the best part
of that black widow movie man she was
incredible i'm so so clear in this show
it's the first time like they had a
movie set up for a show it's like a show
and that really actually paid off and
now it's like fully connected yeah
damn it
give us the post credits
what post credit scene i don't want to
think about what i have wait wait wait
they haven't got away usually it's like
usually it's watch this usually it's
like keep watching disney watch
themselves
give us more take us more action we have
more episodes you want more of our shows
we got what do you want
prepare to be
disappointed prepare to be disappointed
that way yep
why go to it when the cast is showing up
all right i love chongqi but i wanted
kingpin more mephisto it's a mephisto
all over right now
okay awesome that was it was another
really good episode man i would say that
would be my third second favorite out of
the four so far for sure um quite
enjoyed it a lot
um
okay i should clarify really fast i
already hear the comments from people
you know because i said the thing about
like this is the first time when yeah
the movie said something to watch the
show like yes i know that we have one
division and loki like those things set
up the show but this was the first time
character introduced in a movie like a
fully formed character introduced where
they were like for
they really where we heard about the
hawkeye show announced already in
advance yeah before black widow came out
greg don't worry there was blood in
falcon or soldier so i was wrong because
the blood's splattering we'd already
seen it
frankly the blood on the shield yeah i'm
an idiot that was the first time where
they were like black widow show this
character will continue on if you like
for this post-credits scene go watch
hawkeye and people just want to be
semantic about it
but it felt good that payoff i agree
with you it was a great payoff man it
was exciting to see her again yeah
dressed as night monkey yeah
the night monkey cameo really surprised
me that's true she was like you know
what i'm going to take on this other
identity he's big in europe
yeah that's perfect they won't recognize
him he's very subtle she's like i'm
going to turn this good guy into a bad
guy in america i'm so glad you caught on
that it was elena right away because my
mind was like are they bringing in
daredevils
[Music]
in one of the black widow moves like she
did one of the trademark black widow
moves my brain went and immediately
natasha was like no wait you'll light up
and it was it was that starter of like
oh okay that's amazing yeah
that attention to detail i love this
slow reveal of
of her especially when they use the the
because if you don't know those are
called
the widows
just called gauntlets i think so okay
wrist thingies
black widow thingies black widow tech
this episode's so woke night monkeys
three women at the end
whoa fighting
fighting the first fight
fighting one white
so
send this video to your favorite youtube
channel
feel the comments actually feel them
percolating let them clip it
let them clip it yeah let them think
that we're supporting this
get a whole new bunch of audience you
know
satisfiers it works both ways that's
some people think that when we make
jokes like that that it's like all
you're doing is feeding
feeding them you're too paid too much
attention to them yeah they're laughing
at you once you're laughing
there's no way it's just a snake eating
its tail of [ __ ]
um yeah i mean elena's showing up was
awesome i i think this had
see the sec that the third episode uh i
thought was like the best overall
episode into so far in terms of
construct and in terms of like the
action and the mood the tension this had
surprisingly really great scene work
that i was just really enjoying like i i
loved the scene with jack and and
eleanor when they're in front of kate
and it's like you know there's some
reveal coming around here that
uh that's gonna be i don't remember the
how the structure of the episode was if
clint learned already who jack really
was
prior
to that scene where kate you see her
warming up affectionately towards i
think it's immediately after is it
immediate because she i think you talk
to someone
while she's there right okay so they're
interested so you see like the way she's
reacting as kate is starting her
reaction channel in that moment
very commentary very sincere but the way
the dialogue was it felt like just a
real moment i think this is the best
acting of the show so this episode is
like an acting showcase like i kept
thinking like this would be good in an
acting class like there were a bunch of
great acting showcase scenes and i think
it's really smart to end the second act
with all this drama to endear us to
these characters that way the punches
went twice yeah in the third act which
is the next two episodes yeah the
teamwork was great oh yeah well and
haley steinfeld's reaction to everything
they were doing caught me off because
like she's starting to get endeared by
it and then i was starting to get
endeared by it and then i was like wait
no i don't trust you i don't trust that
mustache but yeah like i was right there
with her in her performance of that beat
and that flavor that that emotion and so
yeah it was a nice nuance to get after
so much angst between just that triangle
of characters you know it is interesting
how they're doing so many different
things with jack compared to the comics
sorry for ruining that for everyone
prior uh
we can't unknow and also like why would
you watch people that have been formed
to not like what do people want
but okay i mean yeah because with the
comics like swordsman was the character
who who trained who helped train clint
when in the circus and you find out he's
like a bad guy eventually but there's
other versions in the comics where clint
actually i mean uh jack is
you know trying to do good right trying
to join the avengers and [ __ ] yeah yeah
so he is he can flip-flop there but this
is like hawkeye hawkeye was a bad guy
yeah so huh guy tried to rob the
avengers in his first appearance which
is why it was fun in the avengers movie
how they had him be like right because
it leaned into that it was also very fun
for jeremy renner reportedly to do that
for the fight
yeah like that's such a human thing
especially someone who is whose first
language is not american uh american
they don't speak
uh to get like the to get the quotes
in
the first time you have like 130
punch drunken guys
like getting the quotes wrong and then
watching them laugh about it it felt so
sincere and authentic also the same with
renner talking about ronin like that
entire sequence about nat evolving into
ronan that the sequence going from this
adorable christmas scene which i i've
loved that the show's been so
christmas-based but that scene was like
full constant like christmas from
concentrate and then that turning into
this really dark ending um and then the
morning wake up like it was just that
section to me was such a highlight of
kate and clint's relationship it was so
it was that's that's just great it's
just great writing to me yeah like
starting off with a year
you're lonely on christmas oh yeah yeah
the dichotomy of their life and she left
the loving family environment to be with
him yeah which shows their relationship
him willing to sacrifice his loving
family for her and like literally
nursing himself with margaritas and then
even teaching her a little bit like yeah
i wonder if that coin thing is going to
come into play or something
yeah he's going to ram a coin through
somebody's like forehead kingpin
it's done so kingpin dies she's actually
bullseye
has to fight colin farrell multiverse
goes through the head this is not he's
doing hawkeye does that guy's gonna be
the introduction in the multiverse
everybody's coming you guys and then
they bring
[Laughter]
the most broad cosmic
sides of the universe
definitely belonging in this universe
last episode takes place entirely in
hell
tracksuit mafia is mephisto oh my god i
would love it
he's a demon
so let's get back
no i think we should riff twenty minutes
yeah yeah that'd be great
um
and uh it said that after that scene
but no okay yeah the jeremy renner
monologue was excellent i loved like the
the uh the irony towards the fact of
like you see him as family man in that
moment yeah and it's kind of hard to
imagine like just a we saw him be wrong
in an avengers end game and then it had
like it was new footage new footage
i wonder it seemed like there was a mix
of i mean obviously it was a mix of
footage from avengers and game but some
of that looked like they shot it for
either they shot it for this show or
it's some deleted scenes from game three
yeah so it could be either or but i i
thought like that was such a human
just a human performance like to me
that's that that subtlety of jeremy
renner of how much he internalizes i
think is a big part of what makes him
such a fantastic actor and the way they
react off one another like is like a big
part of acting they say is reacting
listening and the way how haley
steinfeld is taking in his words
receiving it i think makes that scene
just so complementary with the both of
them so yeah i mean this is a great
scene work overall i don't [ __ ]
really forget that laura they gave her
some [ __ ] also linda carter yeah yeah
yeah and her speaking like you know
multiple languages and code and going
through all the like spy work and stuff
yeah i also i think we we look at these
shows as we get a lot of two-person
scenes because we have six hours like we
get to actually invest again semantics
five hours and whatever minutes
but like we get so many moments where
it's like paul bettany got to have these
great liz olson scenes we got you know
falcon winner soldier we got sebastian
sands and anthony mack's relationship
growing we got owen wilson and tom
hiddleston now we have this duo and all
of these pairs are so well cast and the
chemistry is all so amazing that i think
it's going to make the movies so much
more enhanced when they then get brought
in like when we when we see liz olsen in
doctor strange i'm gonna be so much more
invested because we've grown with those
beautiful like duality of scenes so when
we have the inevitable young avengers
show we're gonna love kate bishop all
the more because of her beautiful
relationship with clint who we've always
wanted more of so i think what they're
doing at disney plus is genius for
exponential growth of emotional
attachment yeah a thousand percent man
yeah and i mean the growth up until the
end of the episode i thought was really
nicely handled because you know you see
these conflicts arising especially as
like clint's confessing to who or or
kate's putting together who he really is
and leading up to it's like this is the
first episode where it really clicked
for me like this they are feeling like a
really natural not buddy cop but you
know like that kind of team where it's
like yeah one of them is is like i love
a performance when somebody's like tired
and over this and just wants to like go
home like jeremy renner is so good at
that and then her like pep it's like
yeah they're archetypes in a way but
they feel so natural in the hands of
these two and the situation the way it
escalates ultimately you know coming up
to they don't have a plan she's breaking
in she's following her own you know sort
of uh approach to that and like it's so
charming but then when it gets real and
they get ambushed you know and he starts
to you know he's basically saying this
is going way far up the chain and now
there's a black widow involved this is
like i really bought the escalation of
of
their ultimate you know before the act
three separation where it's like you
gotta get out of here because this is
way too real now well i think i mean i
like the i like the reluctant mentor
situation here that has happened with
him because this was the episode where
he was he's always been reluctant but
then he started seeming like he was
really warming up like even though he
had a talking with the parents the next
day he's like all right kate here's your
mission yeah you know like yeah oh no
we're still team hawkeye yeah yeah and
then it ends on this note and it's gonna
permanently stay that way we know it
guys all of us know yeah that's it end
of season and the end of kate bishop
guys she's gone
give up the boat go home and be
responsible
yeah yeah
raise pizza dog and probably get married
settling in well i think what happened
to college guys as i'm making this
thumbnail um i cannot believe we did not
touch on one of my favorite moments of
this episode uh it's closer towards the
end
when
kate when kate falls off of the rooftop
and then clint catches her
and the christmas lights are behind her
and the way the camera cuts back and
forth it's such strong visual
storytelling language because it's that
moment right then and there as all of us
picked up on when you know clint is
deciding she cannot be a part of this
any longer there's no way she can be a
part of this because obviously that is
reminding him of the last time that he
saw natasha he's having this fight with
the black widow on the rooftop they do
flash back to that moment in this
episode when he's having his whole
speech talking about being ronin and
then talking about the the shot that he
didn't take
in many of the episodes i have uh i feel
like they've at least acknowledged
natasha like a few times by now and even
in clint's opening scene at the rogers
the musical play
they it it really slows down and
captures the trauma that clintus
experienced over the loss of her that i
love that they didn't even rely on
flashbacks in that moment like as if you
know of henderson game you know that
scene you know that that's exactly what
that's calling back to and i love just
the the subtlety of expression in jeremy
renner's performance at that moment
showcasing
that that is the moment he is making the
decision
that he cannot put kate down on this
path because he's afraid this this will
lead to her demise
such great moment such a great moment i
think what happened with this episode um
that that really shifted a lot for me
was they were obviously doing it but i
think they made it abundantly clear
because part of the motivation i i've
heard people talk about this and i was
sort of feeling it too that in the first
couple episodes it seemed like
clint was doing this mission because it
was like this freaking cake girl's got
in and over ahead and i gotta look out
for her and help her and protect her and
that's part of it but this episode
really established that motivation of
why he's here is the fact that it it is
the sins of his past it is the ronin
that he has to click he has to clean up
all that like this is he feels like this
is all his fault
i love him hesitating to tell her after
she accused him you could see him
processing because he's such a good
actor and then committing to it and then
yeah also acknowledging he's here for
both reasons which he always seemed like
he felt guilty about which is brilliant
acting i also love this the first time
and maybe it's because black widow did a
really i thought great job in the third
act showing the assassins that are the
black widow like moniker this to me when
he said like a black widow assassin it
didn't feel cheesy like another natasha
as like an action figure like i believe
in this underground world of black widow
assassins to a level where like this mcu
now has black widow assassins to a lover
i'm like oh that's cool it didn't feel
like oh we have another like
when you're playing capcom versus marvel
and two people click pack whatever like
another color like it
actually feels like there's
a shame yeah it feels like there's black
assassins in this universe yeah not like
a skin yeah yeah it makes the the the
different factions of the world feel
more alive and like they are just out
there and all kind of keeping an eye on
each other yeah there's much more going
on as of phase four
and there's some things that i think
rhythmically though that with this
series it makes me question if i mean
it's released week to week and seriously
so yeah would it flow as as a binge
it's not supposed to be a [ __ ] it's
released week to week so does that
question matter no probably not
uh so there's that there are some
moments that i thought were a little bit
odd like when you first hear clint on
the earpiece
when i mean i thought it was it was
really apparent why those flashing
lights were in that room
yeah and then the adventures like you
worked for wait a minute get out so
there's a security trip
like your security company yeah
break into somebody's place and flashing
lights i just assume that that
yeah it's christmas lights christmas
light
means
lights they're very aggressive they're
just two christmas lights in the corner
holly jolly
yeah
so there was that and but also when you
do hear clint talking to um
when he thinks he's fighting maya on the
rooftop before the reveal her
the there's no like grunting i'm hearing
going on and this is like nitpicking but
i think little things like this help
enhance intensity on certain scenes well
you heard grunting and then when you
spoke to grunting was gone that's what
bothered me is like yes it was like a
tussle and then it was like but i'm fine
yeah and then they went back and they
were fighting like fighting right now
yeah yeah i was at that same dry
delivery without sounding like he's in a
fight yeah he's an adr issue when this
one did not have his screw this show
that's it we're
is like the third episode stands so high
because it has a little bit of
everything that you would want and it's
all in a really well-rounded and a
really well proportioned and paced
package and i didn't have like a problem
with the pace or the proportions of this
episode but it didn't feel like it was
completely rounded it felt more like a
component or an installment
with something greater around it which
they all are but it didn't just it
didn't feel as much like a standalone
episode what is the main mission at hand
clear get rid of ronin's name
but also see how high this thing is
see how high this goes track supermodels
elena's trying to kill quinn
kingpin's trying to get the tracksuit
his nose is clean maya is trying to kill
ronan kay bishop's trying to be fancy
she's like she wants to be a fool the
larpers just want a large they just want
a larva those people just don't stop
larping they don't even go to their real
job and i think madame mask wants to
claim territory of kingpins and i think
that's weird for manga
don't bring up characters who aren't in
the direct text of these episodes who do
i think i am assuming things that might
or might not be true and therefore
accidentally spoiling my this theorizing
i don't know i mean we're on the episode
five and six i feel like it's a little
bit a little late well that's what i was
that's exactly why i'm asking what
there's a lot what's the main what's the
main mission at hand because you would
say it's a clear of the ronin name but
then i was like you got all this stuff
with
jackson mafia
right now it feels like i've just seen
episode four of an eight episodes here
yeah there's a lot left rather than a
sixer and that makes me wonder if the
next two episodes are going to be like
an hour long each because this is the
shortest so far i think they say big guy
at the top
that could just be a saying
because big guy is is usually at the top
excuse me specifically is that they say
big big
big sure big at the top we're talking
like yes with the euphemisms that we
don't know big guy at the top all right
well
listen i give this episode
who cares we're going to finish the show
anyway we'll judge it based on that i
don't like it
no king finn yet guys
that was that was that was fun i really
liked this show um subscribe click that
bell hit that like bell
wait
while you're doing the housekeeping he's
ranking the episode
and i'm sitting here going well you kind
of got to bump up one though for rogers
the musical but anyway but i gotta the
second one's the lethal weapon episode
you can't afford you got the money
confidence boy you guys are both
guys listen we gotta do a quick patron
of the day shout out
john really wants to shout out tyler
hague take it away john tyler hague i
missed you buddy you're the kingpin of
this youtube channel big guy i'm telling
you
easily you're the big guy at the top you
got so many screens you could easily
keep an eye on all of us and pull
strings from your one little penthouse
where you're on house arrest yes because
of all your various crimes i know your
outside persona is very gentle and sweet
and sophisticated but i don't buy it for
a second tyler especially since you sent
him a ps4 and you didn't send me a ps4
that's not a thing that kingpin would do
i'm not bitter about that and i'm not
[Laughter]
and i'm not actually bitter about that
so please do not send me a ps4 i don't
want this to turn into that that's where
to go
we love you tyler and i missed the times
when we used to get on and chat with you
because you really do have a very warm
and a wonderful personality and i hope
you're doing well this holiday season
you are the big man at the top of all of
our hearts you're the kingpin of the
real rejects and we love you
buddy so true man oh yeah you're great
dude i [ __ ] miss you
[Music]